because I told the story about her
matching tattoo matching tattoo with
your ex-best friend yes what does it say
but now it says it's wrong too I'm
afraid of everybody
Google Translate Google Translate why'd
you ask like your dad because it's
Japanese none of this is making he's
Korean I'm Chinese right let's pick
neutral territory Japanese so we both
don't know the language I like that so
it's supposed to be fear no one but
Google translate of course [__] it up
so it's like everyone I fear or
something like that so the way he found
out was my mom was reading it
and a white dude tatted it we got it in
North Carolina the guy's like hey I
don't know the language so I'm just
gonna trust you guys well no we got it
at least he was honest